weren't you shocked how chris's stand-up
got even like more intense after
saturday night
like all of a sudden went to another
level you got to remember i was like in
95 or whatever i'm off
snl i had no career nothing i had
nothing 94 95 93 i'm
off snl were you at the point where you
thought you were out of the business i
was
i was out it wasn't like i thought i was
out i was out of the business i remember
i used to do uh politically incorrect
right when it was on comedy central
right with pat boone
so when you're doing shows with pat
village it's hard to shine
i mean people calling you i mean like
spade was you were off his list i mean
everything now you know what these guys
the snl guys are always cool that's good
that was space well because we all go
through the same stuff
it's hard to it's is it in a shitty
career in a sense that okay you did
great and you ended up being a big
success
but those are just such harrowing years
and scary years don't you sit there in
your house and go what the [ __ ] am i
gonna do i'm a failure i
know cause i'm from bed stuy man so i
was like
even washed up in show business was
still better
than what i was gonna be anyway so did
you sit at home and go
okay saturday night live was okay all of
a sudden i'm washed up and then that
motivated you get out on the road and
really
just amp up the stand up i had no i i
wasn't
no one was gonna put me in a movie right
uh
everyone had seen me on television so no
i wasn't going to get any jobs
and i need a sitcom this was that was
not going to happen
right but i had a credit i had snl
credit and i was in new jack city and
whatever so i had
enough to get some stand up my goal at
that point was to become rich
jenny or george wallace or you know just
a
uh you know don miera just a guy that's
a real
solid standout yeah domino is a great
standard of course i did get right you
know bobby slate
like one of these guys that you know
800 grand a year yeah right and you said
hey that's not a bad living and you were
married at that point right
i wasn't you weren't even there i was
like you know what
if i can live like wallace right wallace
wallace
lives good wallace ain't in no movies
whilst don't have no tv show
but he gets to play vegas wallace plays
vegas and he does his gigs and he
has a new car he's brilliant he flies
all over the world that's right
did you go to guys like seinfeld and say
hey what the [ __ ] am i going to do
nobody would talk to me howard only my
snl guys would talk to me i was
so out of show business and so when you
created what i call a masterpiece the
sergeant peppers of commons yeah
yeah do you ever say to yourself this is
absurd do you ever sit and go oh my god
this is the stupidest [ __ ] thing i
have to stand on a stage and make people
laugh for a living does it ever hit you
like that or do you just
love it i love it you love it he's
better at it i love him he's better at
it and he's
i've been and he's better still but i
heard you're great at it i'm not at the
chris rock but
but do you agonize do you i do i know i
do like it but
the only thing i don't do that chris
does is put in like
a year straight i can't do even four i
can't do two shows in one night i can't
do
five shows in a week it just starts
getting like groundhog's day i start to
freak out
and i forget my and i go is this even
good anymore i start to get weird so you
have a weird thing with it
yeah i had i was talking to don rickles
on the show the other day
and he said to me that he doesn't have a
set act he gets up there and
just wings it i don't believe true that
cannot be true
he's got a set out i know come on you
know what he said farley went to see him
once with his mom
and he goes don reckless walks up and
goes what's your name tiny
chris and he goes this thing came out of
you lady
and he goes how much away chris he goes
about 220 he goes
the left side of your ass
[Laughter]
he's a maybe right but it's have you
seen him live
yes but it's got to be prepared right
it's got to be he prepares a lot of that
stuff
maybe he does maybe he's saying he
doesn't do the same order every night
but
the black guys up in your room stealing
your stuff i mean it's gonna be mixed
around